would poor day could be a good choice to
be the chairman of ofcom uh steve baker
tommy ellie who would be delighted to
see that because he's a conservative
well i think everyone's getting a little
bit ahead of themselves with this we
will be launching
shortly the process for the appointment
of both the chairman of the bbc
and uh the ofcom chair and at that point
applicants will be welcome to to apply
for it
okay so we're getting a bit ahead of
ourselves and but the story has been
clearly brief to the sunday newspapers
number 10 have decided to put the
culture secretary ford for media
interviews suggests that somebody wants
you to talk about it
um paul dacre and charles moore seem to
be the prime minister's choices
are they your first choice too
i think let's let's separate them out
they're two very different appointments
first of all in respect of the chair of
the bbc what we're looking for
is a strong big person who can uh
hold the bbc to account and there's
three things that i've been talking
about with the bbc first of all ensuring
this genuine
impartiality secondly ensuring the bbc
is up to the challenges of the future
as we move from analog through digital
to platform technology huge changes for
the bbc
and then thirdly ensuring that the bbc
represents all parts of our nation
not just uh narrow metropolitan areas
the london
center of london bristol uh birmingham
and so on bbc is doing now
well i think uh they're working uh
towards it and i think uh tim davey has
made
a good progress with it but it is
important that we have a genuine robust
scrutiny of of the bbc
and looking forward to driving that
agenda
okay paul dako once said that bbc
journalism is reflected through a
left-wing prison
that affects everything in exercise as a
kind of cultural marxism
do you agree with him well i'm not going
to get drawn into conversations about
each of the candidates clearly there's
strengths to both uh charles moore
and to paul daker i've set out what i'd
be looking for in respect of the bbc
we'll launch that process we'll conduct
it in accordance with the charter
similarly in relation to ofcom offcom is
an enormously important economic
regulator covering
everything through mobile broadcasting
through to online harms we need strong
credible people to
to fill those roles and that's what
we're looking for through the
competition process
so if you don't want to be drawn on the
candidates you're a bit irritated that
the prime minister seems to have jumped
the gun
well there's always going to be
speculation about different candidates
we have a clear process
for running this we've been clear about
what we're looking for
i'll be launching the competition for
the bbc and for ofcom
shortly and we'll be conducting that in
the proper way
has the prime minister consulted you
about the appointments
well you would expect that the prime
minister and i discussed these things uh
a great deal these are hugely important
roles both the chair of the bbc
and the chair of of common of course
we've been in touch with each other a
lot about
it okay um now paul daycare also
predicted in 2018 that a right of center
tv network
will one day take root in this country
now a new channel gb news has been
announced with andrew neil the former
bbc presenter
as a chairman do you welcome the idea of
a newcomer and do you think there's a
gap in the market
definitely i think one of the huge
strengths of the united kingdom's
broadcasting scene and indeed it's a
newspaper scene
it's a tremendous plurality and
diversity we often take this for granted
but we're so lucky in the uk to have
for example with newspapers of range
from you know the guardian right through
the telegraph mail no other country in
the world has that kind of diversity
and it is at the absolute heart of our
freedoms in this nation our press
freedom similarly with broadcasting
we're blessed with
brilliant broadcasters whether it's you
here with sky news
bbc many other different ranges of
channels and i welcome any new entrance
to it
a bit of flattery there never never does
any harm certainly
um is it time for ofcombo to have
uh greater powers to regulate online
companies
well yeah we've we have indicated that
for online harms
uh our preferred regulator would be
ofcom i'll shortly be publishing the
response
to the online harms white paper the full
response from the government where we'll
make a formal announcement
about that and this is a very important
area of government policy
at a time when we've all seen how
reliant we are
on online uh particularly during the
covet crisis
we need to ensure that we drive growth
and prosperity
through the digital revolution but also
we're able to protect the most
vulnerable and that's what that
legislation will be about getting that
balance right
and empowering an appropriate regulator
to to do so and as i've said
ofcom is we've indicated our preferred
regulator will formally make that
decision shortly
okay now i'm keen to move on to other
matters
coronavirus of course um when i spoke to
steve baker but earlier
on the programme he was talking about
his concerns about the restrictions
imposed by the government he said to me
liberty dies like this
with government exercising draconian
powers without parliamentary scrutiny
is liberty at risk of dying because of
the government's response to clover19
well i have huge respect for steve baker
i like him enormously but i think that
is
slightly overblown uh where actually it
is important that parliament holds the
government to account that's why for
example
next week we'll be having the first
debate on government time
on covert of course there'll be a risk a
chance for
mps to debate and vote on uh new
measures
through what we call statutory
instruments there'll be votes on that
for example in relation to the
rule of six it's entirely appropriate
should mps be able to vote beforehand i
think that's quite an important
distinction isn't there between
retrospective voting and being able to
vote before things
are enacted well
i think it's important in a crisis like
this when things are moving very rapidly
that the government has the power to
move quickly and that is the power that
the government was given
through the initial legislation earlier
this year but then it's then important
that mps hold us to account
and uh vote on that and that is exactly
what's happening here
and i'm i'm very clear these are very
difficult choices we're making
uh we have a rapidly uh expanding virus
we also have huge economic consequences
from the decisions that we're taking
and we're having to take measures to
deal with that it's entirely right that
uh government ministers are probably
scrutinized by parliament through this
process
okay um it sounds like you think that
the current system is
working uh all right then now uh i want
to talk about local lockdowns uh
millions of people in local lockdowns
already sadiq khan the mayor of london
says now it's time for greater
restrictions on
people in the capital not being able to
visit people's households because of the
rising infection levels
is the government preparing to introduce
tougher restrictions on london
well look in response to the rising
number of uh covert cases
we announced the measures over the past
couple of weeks principally the the rule
of six and then the further restrictions
in the past week of course
we keep all these things under review
but the key thing now
is that people stick to the existing
rules that we have
they observe the rule of sits hands
facing space they
people wash their hands make sure they
wear face coverings particularly uh
indoors and observe social distancing if
we do all of those things
we can keep the virus under control and
keep our economy open and avoid further
restrictions it really is
in the power of everyone watching this
show to make sure they abide by those
rules and prevent further more draconian
restrictions
it's interesting you're really putting
uh you know the blame squarely
on people and and to be fair you know
the study by king's college london
only 18 of people with reported covet 19
symptoms went on to self-isolate
at the same time though you know the
government was the ones telling us all
to kind of eat out to help out
telling us that we needed to do a bit to
get the economy moving and now you're
saying oh no not that much it's your
fault now because of rising infections
you can see why people might be feeling
a bit aggrieved
well sophie i think that's a rather
unfair characterization of what i
just said uh the majority of people up
and down the country
are abiding by the rules but i think
they are frustrated
at a small minority who are not law
abiding
who are putting other people's health at
risk that is why for example
we've doubled uh the fine for not
observing the rules in relation to face
coverings and so on
that's why we've uh said that be up to
ten thousand pounds worth of fines
if people don't observe social isolation
because
no man is an island in in this ev each
person has to take their own
responsibilities
because it will in turn affect everyone
else and the government is taking its
responsibility
both in terms of ensuring the correct
rules are in place but also for example
by ensuring
massive amounts of ppe equipment a huge
upsurge in
a testing capacity we all need to work
together to defeat this terrible virus
uh some minority people then behaving
selfishly
the there is a small minority and that
is why we've um announced more
astringent uh fines in respect of them
um i do feel as well and we need to talk
a bit about young people and university
students you know going to university
always quite stressful time in your life
often away from home for the first time
freshers week cancelled
tutorials online many self-isolating and
now suddenly many also told
they can't even go home at christmas to
see their families and
should university students be allowed to
go home in the holidays
well of course i very much want students
to be able
to go home at christmas and if we all
pull together
and observe these uh new rules or we
follow
the guidance then we will be able to get
to a point where that
should be possible but i have to say to
you sophie that labor raising this
um it all fits a bit with what i heard
from the shadow education secretary a
couple of days ago saying
not let a good crisis go to waste
there's no difference between us we both
want to ensure
that uh students can return at christmas
and rather than sort of playing politics
for this i'd rather labor was urging
everyone to work together to achieve
this outcome
at the same time though you know you're
in no way saying that it is certain that
university students will be able to go
home at christmas so saying that's only
a possible if you know everyone does the
right thing and manages to get the virus
under control that's going to be quite
concerning for people
well we're three months away from
christmas we've announced a range of
measures
we are constantly keeping this situation
under review taking the necessary
measures to keep the virus under control
all of that is designed to ensure that
we keep the virus under control in a way
that will enable people to continue to
to live their lives normally and or as
normally as possible in in this
situation so of course we want to
avoid that that situation but i don't
think it's helpful at this stage three
months away to speculate on that
the thing we should be focusing on now
is ensuring that we
actually uh take these measures and uh
abide by them
okay and now i want to ask you a little
bit about football and live sports
and because of course uh many people
were very excited about the idea of live
crowds
are being allowed back and for many
smaller clubs and teams as well
they're relying on ticket sales to
actually keep afloat
um it's very difficult particularly for
you know for example small
football clubs murtha town fc have
already been mothballed for example
what exactly are you going to do about
this
well nobody could be more disappointed
than me that we weren't able to go ahead
with fans going back into stadium
socially distance from the 1st of
october
but i think most people would agree
against this backdrop of rapidly rising
cases
now was not the time to do it in terms
of our response
now we have said we stand ready to
support
clubs they're such an important part of
our local community
and they were there at the height of the
crisis they had our back and now it's
time for the government to have
their back but the first thing we need
to look to is the premier league
i've been in contact with the premier
league over the course of this week
we're all agreed that the premier league
needs to step up to the plate and
they're having
intensive discussions with the efl about
how they can support
those clubs so they stand ready to play
their part and the prime minister and
i've been clear in urging them
to do that beyond that we are working
across all sports because remember it's
not just
football to see what support they need
are after the decision in relation to
the first of october we've engaged with
them and i've actually asked for them
all to provide formal returns by
wednesday of exactly their their
situation and we're looking at a range
of measures that we could
uh introduce in order to help and
support them through this difficult time
you mentioned there about the premier
league trying to step in
and of course big clubs are the ones who
are most financially able to survive
this difficult period it's much smaller
clubs
that are more likely to really uh be
reliant on those
live crowds so what's your assessment
then at the premier league preparing
something
well uh the premier league and the efl
are in intense discussions i believe
uh there's a meeting taking place on
tuesday of the premier league the
direction is clear
we understand that uh premier league
needs to play its part i'm in close
consultation with them
and i'm hopeful that they will be able
to reach a deal to
provide that that level of support and
just finally are we likely to see
crowns at football matches before the
end of the season
well of course i i desperately love that
to happen
and we keep the situation under constant
review but not only that we are
continuing to
to work ahead investigating the use of
new
technology working with the clubs who've
done such a fantastic job
up to now if it is at all possible of
course i'd like that to happen but
i think you and your viewers will
appreciate that in this rapidly moving
situation with the virus
we just need to exercise a little bit of
caution which is what we have
done in relation to the first of october